Luffy’s Devil Fruit Powers are pretty much
the single most important thing in all of
One Piece.
For the longest time we thought that Luffy
is someone so strong-willed and fearless,
that he somehow overcomes the seemingly weak
powers of his Rubber devil fruit again and
again, for most of the story grinding his
way past enemies with way stronger devil fruit
powers.
That’s until his epic battle with Kaido,
where we find out that it has actually been
the other way around all along.
In reality Luffy has been the person with
possibly the strongest devil fruit in the
story, that allows him to turn anything he
imagines into reality.
However, Shanks gave it a fake name and tricked
Luffy into using it in its weakest form for
almost the entire story.
Which in a way makes it even more impressive
that he has managed to come this far while
holding back like 99% of his true power.
But that leaves a really interesting question
on the table, that every real one piece fan
has asked themselves before: What would have
happened if Luffy had eaten another extremely
overpowered devil fruit as a kid?
Now, of course there are many ultra powerful
fruits in the story to choose from, like Enel’s
lightning fruit, Kaido’s dragon fruit or
Whitebeard’s Earthquake fruit.
And if you want to see me cover those fruits
in another video soon, make sure that you’re
subscribed to the channel.
But for today, to make things a bit easier,
I’ve decided on 5 devil fruits that I would
just love to see Luffy use in the actual story:
And these are the devil fruits of the 5 Marine
Admirals: Aokiji’s Ice fruit, Kizaru’s
Light Fruit, Akainu’s Magma Fruit, Fujitora’s
Gravity Fruit and Greenbull’s Forest fruit.
If Luffy had eaten each of these 5 ridiculously
overpowered fruits, how would the course of
Luffy’s journey have changed significantly?
And how would Luffy have used all these fruits
compared to the admirals?
We begin in Luffy’s childhood, where Luffy
accidentally eats the devil fruit that Shanks
and his crew have just stolen from a marine
ship.
And we know that Shanks got his hands on Luffy’s
furit on purpose, because it is important.
To give Luffy a different devil fruit, let’s
just assume that Shanks has not only one,
but two devil fruits with him.
And instead of the purple rubber fruit, hungry
kid Luffy eats the second one.
Now, as you might know, all the admiral’s
devil fruit powers share one similarity: They
belong to a category called Logia, which turn
their users entire body into a force of nature.
The only exception here is Fujitora’s Gravity
fruit, because we actually don’t know if
it is Logia fruit like the others, or just
a regular ability, that has no effect on his
body.
For the sake of this video, we will go with
regular fruit, just to make things a bit more
interesting.
So depending on each fruit, when Luffy eats
the devil fruit by accident and shanks grabs
him, instead of his arm stretching, Luffy’s
body reacts different.
For the ice fruit, he might freeze shanks’
arm.
For the light fruit, Shanks’ hand just passes
through Luffy.
For the magma fruit, Shanks burns himself
trying to touch luffy.
For the gravity fruit Shanks is suddenly smashed
into the ground and for the forest fruit luffy
just sprouts a little flower on his head and
his feet grow roots into the wooden floor
of the pub.
Now, the question if of course, what would
happen to Luffy’s original devil fruit in
this scenario?
Well, Shanks would give that fruit to Luffy’s
future brother Ace, the son of Gol D. Roger,
who also was Shanks’ captain.
In case you wonder why, I actually made a
whole video on what would happen if Luffy
was never born, where I explain in detail
why Shanks was originally looking for Ace
to give him this devil fruit and how Luffy
accidentally eating it, changed his and Roger’s
entire plan.
I recommend you check that out later.
But yeah, for our scenario here, Luffy has
now eaten a powerful logia fruit and Ace is
the one to eat the Nika fruit.
Now one big question we need to ask ourselves
is of course: Would Shanks still sacrifice
his arm for Luffy and give him his straw hat,
if Luffy didn’t become the chosen one?
I think there is a real argument to be made
here, that Shanks would rather try to inspire
Ace to become pirate king.
On the other hand, Shanks really took a liking
to Luffy even before he ate the devil fruit,
and i think he would still come to save Luffy,
especially after he was willing to fight the
mountain bandits to defend the red hair pirates’
honour.
So yes, I think Shanks would still save Luffy
and inspire him to become a great pirate,
just because he likes Luffy.
However I think in this case, Shanks would
decide to keep his arm instead.
Ace would most likely not want his father’s
straw hat, because he blamed Roger for all
his suffering.
In case you didn’t know, Luffy’s hat used
to belong to Roger before he gave it to Shanks.
And so I think it’s fair to assume that
Luffy would still end up getting the hat.
After that, Luffy’s childhood stays pretty
much the same, only that he now learns to
use his logia fruit powers instead of rubber
powers, who now belong to his brother ace.
So let’s get to the juicy bit and jump 10
years into the future, where Luffy leaves
his home island to start his own crew.
With 4 of the 5 fruits he would leave in his
small boat and end up in the barrel on Koby’s
ship.
If Luffy ate Aokiji’s ice fruit however,
I think he would be powerful enough after
10 years of training to freeze the ocean under
his feet and simply start walking across the
ocean, similar to how Aokiji uses his ability
to bike across the water.
In that case, he would probably still get
lost and somehow end up running into Kobe.
Now, with Luffy having such overpowered abilities,
the journey through the east blue is even
easier than before.
Luffy defeats Alvida, Morgan, Buggy, Kuro,
Don Krieg and Arlong with ease, who have absolutely
no chance against any of his 5 abilities.
Since we can assume that none of these enemies
has mastered any form of Haki, they wouldn’t
even be able to touch Luffy.
And even if it’s Luffy having the Gravity
powers, he would simply crush any of them
under a pile of rubble before they could even
come close to him.
There is only one real obstacle for this version
of Luffy before entering the Grandline: And
that’s Smoker.
In case you forgot, Smoker is Luffy’s marine
rival throughout the first half of the story
and the first Logia fruit user we meet in
the story.
And since Luffy himself hasn’t mastered
Haki either, he can only win against another
Logia fruit user, if his element is the natural
weakness of his opponent’s element.
However, on top of that, Smoker also carries
a very unique weapon.
The tip of it has been coated in a material
called sea prism stone, that nullifies any
devil fruit ability.
That means that even the invulnerable bodies
of a logia fruit user would become solid again.
So, just like in the main story line, Luffy
would not be able to beat Smoker.
Wood has no effect on smoke whatsoever.
Ice and Magma can maybe create some sort of
wind to mess with Smoker a bit, but I don’t
think that it would be enough to stop or even
defeat him.
And since smoke is extremely light, Luffy
would need to have mastered his gravity powers
to an incredibly high level so that he could
affect Smoker here at all.
Which i think is unlikely.
Instead, Dragon once again has to step in
and save his son from the marine.
The only exception here, would be Kizaru’s
light fruit.
Because it is so fast, that luffy would be
able to run away from Smoker and maybe even
blind him to get away.
And as you’ll see, as we enter the first
half of the grandline, this will be a sort
of pattern until we finally start to face
characters who know Haki and until Luffy learns
Haki himself.
Enemies that seem to have no haki abilities,
such as Wapol or Moria have no chance against
Luffy, because they literally can’t touch
him.
Does Rob Lucci and the rest of CP9 have haki
before the timeskip?
On the one hand, it would be strange if they
did not, given that they are special agents,
but at the same time, there is no hint what
so ever, that any of them is using any form
of Haki during their battle with the straw
hats on Enies Lobby.
So I think that only gravity Luffy would have
any trouble with Lucci, although even then,
Luffy would be powerful enough to take him
down and probably collapse all of Enies Lobby
with him.
The real challenges during this part of the
journey, until we come to the war at Marineford,
are of course the other Logia users in the
story.
Starting with the one and only sir crocodile,
the main antagonist of the alabasta saga.
As you probably remember, Crocodile ate the
dryness or sand logia devil fruit.
And Luffy was only able to beat him by coating
himself in water and his own blood, since
humidity is dryness’ natural weakness.
So how would Logia luffy without any Haki
do against Crocodile?
It really comes down to match-ups here.
Luffy having AOkiji’s ice powers, should
absolutely be able to win.
Ice is quite solid and you can’t simply
dry it out, like a puddle of water.
At the same time, given the high temperatures
in the desert country of Alabasta, Luffy would
be slightly melting on the surface all the
time, imitating the same effect he used to
defeat crocodile in the actual Story.
With Greenbull’s devil fruit on the other
hand, Luffy would have been defeated very
fast.
Luffy’s forest powers would be absolutely
useless in the desert and even worse against
crocodile, who would be able to dry up any
of Luffy’s attacks and luffy himself.
Similarly, the light fruit would be pretty
ineffective against Crocodile, who mostly
likely also had Haki at this point in the
story.
In both those cases, Luffy would have had
to resort to the very same water trick as
in the main story.
If Luffy had Gravity powers, I do think he
would have a quite decent chance to hurt Crocodile,
simply by crushing him into the ground, sand
particles or not.
And the almighty magma fruit would simply
melt Crocodile’s sand and overwhelm it.
We know that, because Crocodile managed to
block one of Akainu’s attacks during Marineford,
but was trying to get away from the admiral
as fast as possible to avoid taking more damage.
Enel on the other hand, would be a completely
different story.
The lightning fruit is arguably one of the
5 strongest fruits in the entire story and
one of the most powerful logia fruits.
Luffy was able to beat Enel because his rubber
features made him immune to electricity.
But how would Luffy have done against Enel
with a different devil fruit?
The light fruit at first glance seems quite
similar to Enel’s powers and you might think
that light and electricity don’t really
affect each other much.
But then again, Light is just the byproduct
of high energy and heat, so you could think
of light Luffy as a living light bulb, that
could absorb all of Enel’s lightning and
turn it into energy himself.
Gravity on the other hand has no effect on
the much stronger electrical force in the
universe.
In this case, Luffy would lose quite quickly
to Enel.
Similarly, Forest Luffy would not be able
to touch Enel at all.
In return, we have seen that Enel is more
than capable of destroying plants and trees
with his crazy lightning bolds.
So far Greenbull’s forest fruit seems to
be the worst option for Luffy.
As for Ice and Magma, these could arguably
go either way, depending how these powers
actually work in one piece.
For ice, if Enel’s powers are stronger than
Luffy’s, the heat from his electricity would
start melting luffy and the more water there
is on luffy’s body, the more electricity
it conducts, the quicker luffy is defeated
by it.
on the other hand, if luffy’s ice powers
are as crazy as Aokiji’s cold can actually
slow down electrons.
basically reducing Enel’s electricity powers.
Similarly, having Akainu’s magma powers,
luffy could turn the area around him into
hard rocky ground, which doesn’t conduct
any electricity.
However magma itself, since it’s a hot liquid,
actually conducts electricity extremely well.
So who would win?
I think it comes down to who is more experienced
with their fruit power.
Similar to both Aokiji and Akainu would have
been able to overpower each other.
Extreme cold can make Magma useless, while
extreme hot can melt ice.
A question of pure endurance and power.
Of course there are also the encounters with
Aokiji and Kizaru on Sabaody.
Now we could do the physics here again, but
the truth is, clearly they would be way more
skilled with their logia fruits than Luffy
and on top of that also have extremely powerful
haki, so i don’t think Luffy would have
a real chance against either here.
Then we have Luffy’s encounter with Blackbeard
in Impel Down.
Now Blackbeard is interesting.
His darkness fruit is supposed to be the strongest
logia fruit alive.
However it doesn’t behave like a logia fruit
at all.
Blackbeard’s darkness has strong properties
of both gravity and absorption.
He can pull things towards and into him.
Plus when he touches someone, Blackbeard is
able to nullify their devil fruit powers.
So we’ll have to wait and see if this fruit
truly is a logia fruit or whether it might
now be something else, similar to Luffy’s
fruit.
Now, it would seem like Luffy having Kizaru’s
light powers would be perfect against darkness.
However we know that even light can’t escape
form Blackbeards Darkness.
On the other hand, Teach is very vulnerable
to physical attacks, so especially the gravity
fruit would seem quite capable of taking him
down here, since it’s the only fruit where
blackbeard could not make contact with Luffy’s
body to nullify his powers.
And if Luffy could stop teach here, that would
of course change a whole lot of things in
the story.
For the war at Marineford, really any of Luffy’s
new powers would be of much more use than
his rubber powers were in the main time line.
I think that especially Greenbull’s forest
fruit would absolutley shine here for the
first time ever.
After all, it is particularly useful when
attacking a large number of weaker enemies.
Luffy can take out whole squads of Marine
soldiers at once, absorbing their energy to
heal himself.
He could also use his roots to sneakily free
ace much faster, giving him a much better
chance to survive.
And as a bonus, we do know that the forest
fruit is actually NOT weak to fire, something
that Greenbull shows us when momonosuke tries
to set him on fire.
So Luffy would have a way better chance standing
up to akainu and causing a bit of trouble
for him.
However overall, Luffy would only become a
true monster with all these fruits, after
honing his skills with them for 2 years with
Rayleigh and combining them with Haki.
So after the time skip, Luffy would once again
go through the first three enemies with ease.
Fishman island, Ceasar on Punk Hazard and
even Doflamingo on Dressrosa, would stand
not even the slightest chance against any
of these 5 Luffy’s.
Luffy would also have no problems taking out
Katakuri and in case of the Magma fruit, you
could even argue that Luffy would be able
to put up a real fight against Big mom at
that point.
He definitely would not be captured by Big
Mom’s army.
And if he had the ice devil fruit, fleeing
Whole Cake island would also have been a piece
of cake.
lol.
So the real question is of course: What would
have happened against Kaido in Wano?
Let’s say Luffy also awakens his devil fruit
there once again.
Now admittedly, we don’t quite know yet
what an awakened Logia fruit is truly capable
of, but it’s very likely that many of the
crazy islands in the grand line were actually
shaped by awakened logia users in the past.
So here’s my prediciton: I think that forest
luffy would once again lose.
No way trees and plants would be able to seriously
damage Kaido with his wind blades and hardened
skin.
Luffy with the magma fruit could go either
way.
Akainu’s fruit awakened sounds truly terrifying,
but then again, Kaido can fly.
Though he did end up in magma in the end to
be fair.
Luffy with Kizaru’s fruit would have a pretty
decent chance to win I think.
If Luffy advances his armament and conquorer’s
haki as much as in the main story line, he
should be both fast and powerful enough with
his light powers to take Kaido out.
Similarly he could use both Gravity and Ice
to keep Kaido out of the air and slowly grind
him down over time.
The gravity fruit would be useful to bombard
Kaido with meteors, but that would also destroy
the entire island of onigashima, so it might
actually be a bit of a draw back here.
And I would actually argue that after wano,
Luffy’s actual devil fruit has turned out
to be even more powerful than any of these
5 anyways.
So maybe the much more interesting question
to ask here is not what would have happened
if Luffy did all the same stuff but with a
different devil fruit, but what would have
happened to the one piece world, if Luffy
with his legendary Devil Fruit had been allowed
to join Shanks and his crew as a kid?
Because that one is a much crazier timeline
than this.
If you’re curious you can watch that one
right here.
Shanks for watching.